- My favorite part about doing murals is
the opportunity to reach someone that
usually wouldn't be around me.
This mural is called "Breathe Deep."
I believe that you learn your best lessons
when you're not expecting to learn.
(upbeat hip hop music)
My name is Fabian Williams.
I'm an artist working in
the great city of Atlanta.
I've done over a dozen murals in the city.
I came from advertising, and
the type of work that I used to do
was primarily to sell
products that you don't need.
At a certain point, I just kinda felt like
I was using my powers
for the wrong reasons.
My work is a mix of
race, politics, and ...
humor.
So I painted Martin Luther King
floating up in space,
pointing down at you,
because you have to do the work.
You have to realize the dream.
I've come to believe that space is wisdom.
And when I imagine where
someone like Martin Luther King
came from and went back
to, it would be space.
I chose Hosea because his
story is kind of amazing.
He was a Purple Heat recipient.
He was like the general of
the Poor People's Campaign
under Martin Luther King.
He joined the Civil Rights Movement.
He did a lot of community building.
He did a lot of really great things.
The conversation that
I'm having with my work
is that we need new leaders.
I want someone to walk
by one of those murals
and feel a connection.
There's another Hosea Williams here.
There's another Martin
Luther King Jr. here.
They're walking around here,
they just don't know it yet.
These kids should be able to get up
and walk outside the
house and be inspired.